Hi everyone, I'm Sam from the Free Wings flight school and today we'll work through the topic of flight practice together.
Flight practice — and we're sitting here in a studio, which doesn't quite fit together.
What we want to do first is acquire knowledge, and that's something we have to, or can, do well in the theory part.
Because when we have the knowledge, we can go out and train, and once we've trained, we can move on to the area of skill.
And only this path works: acquiring knowledge, training, and then moving into skill.
If you skip one of these, it usually doesn't go well.
So we're concentrating here on acquiring the knowledge of flight practice.
The goal of this course is ultimately that you pass the flight-practice theme of the SHV theory exam without trouble,
ideally with full marks.
Of course best with 100 points, i.e. 100%.
That's the right approach at the end.
For all of this, as practice also says, it's helpful to imagine the whole thing like a flight.
Meaning, we actually start flying at home.
Flying is something you have to prepare.
It's usually not great to simply go straight to the launch site without any prior preparation
and then be surprised by what you encounter.
If you think at home about what you actually want to do today,
that can make things much easier.
And that includes the very first thing — namely, whether you're even fit to fly.
That means: do I actually know what my condition is?
Am I clear-headed?
Have I not had any rough nights and am still half hung over?
Am I fit?
Have I taken any medication that, if I have some kind of pain, might mask it?
Those are all things that can affect us heavily and may make flying unwise.
And also important that we gather information about the weather and the things that affect us.
There's a very simple rule for this, the so-called FFG rule.
That's now in relation to the weather.
If we keep this in mind — currently in the Corona era,
the FFP2 mask is missing as a word.
As a memory aid, we have the FFG rule.
And the FFG rule is nothing other than: do we expect a hazard
called foehn?
Do we expect a hazard
called front?
And do we expect a hazard
called thunderstorm?
If one of these three appears in the weather report,
our ears need to grow very big
and we need to hear what's going on.
Because, as you know — a front, which also comes up in detail in the meteo part of this course,
usually brings a lot of wind with it.
Strong wind is always rather bad for paragliding,
because we travel relatively slowly.
Foehn is generally a dangerous situation.
As a student you don't belong in the air.
Later, when you're very experienced,
there are geographic locations
that can allow flying even in foehn.
But that takes a lot of prior knowledge.
And thunderstorms — also very unpredictable.
You have to have lots of experience.
And in general with thunderstorms, it's better to
land freely and safely
than to try to squeeze out some flight,
which usually doesn't end well.
Then it's important to recognise the requirements.
Also regarding rules and regulations.
Of course there's a glider chart
that describes the legal situation.
And there are also airspace restrictions
that can be quite severe if you don't know about them.
And to find out about these airspace restrictions,
you have to check the DABS for each flight day,
to see whether a current airspace restriction is in effect.
It can be something big,
such as the World Economic Forum in Davos,
where the airspace is closed over a very wide area.
And I can imagine
that there too, if you tried to fly in,
you'd very quickly get an escort
from somewhat larger aircraft,
since a paraglider
would be rather unwise to fly into that.
There are also small restrictions,
for example, if there's a vote,
the country has a referendum,
the country-square is full of people,
there's a cylinder above it
where it's also forbidden
to fly over it,
simply because there's a very large gathering of people.
You'll find this information on the DABS,
described relatively well.
And of course you also have to pay attention
to where you want to fly,
for example on a cross-country flight,
and those are military flights,
military operating hours — important
that you know them,
because depending on the time you can fly higher
than when the military is active.
On the weekend it's a bit less restrictive
than during the week, for example.
What also belongs to this is
checking the equipment,
knowing
that the gear you have with you works.
That includes, for example, charging the batteries.
It's no use if you end up in an emergency situation
and your phone battery is empty,
then you can't tell anyone where you are.
And also the gear in general,
the condition of the wing,
that it's okay,
if you've had a long flying break,
but also being sure
that the reserve parachute is freshly packed.
You should have it repacked at least once a year.
By someone who really knows how to do it.
And the wing itself, knowing
that the condition you stored it in
comes back out the same way.
Meaning, it wouldn't be smart
to pack up the wing
if it just landed in muck
and the muck is on the wing
and the wing then spends weeks in the car boot,
where it's warm.
Those are all things
that will come up later in the equipment course,
that aren't good for the wing.
And of course it can also happen
that accordingly, what you expect
isn't what you find.
Also important
is bringing provisions,
having enough to drink with you.
Drinking is actually the most important thing.
Food is usually such
that you can get energy quickly
from energy bars.
Drinking is often forgotten
and sometimes also deliberately not done,
because it has a small drawback
when you drink a lot.
You also have to go to the toilet.
But there are solutions for that too,
such as urinal condoms,
where you can even pee in the air.
And for women there are also nappies,
so this problem can be solved.
But it's not smart
to skip drinking because of this issue.
Drinking is very important
so we stay sharp,
stay fit in the air,
and so the end of the flying day
isn't ruined by a headache
that we'd have
if we drank too little.
Then, once we've done all the preparation
at home,
it makes sense
to look at the landing site first.
Because at the landing site especially
dangers are obvious,
because you have relatively little altitude
as you approach it.
And it's good
to already know it.
That means a proper landing-site inspection
absolutely makes sense.
We already check
where there are possible obstacles,
for instance cables
that are nearby,
running across the valley.
Where there's a big tree, for example,
that you might have to take into account
when planning your landing pattern.
And in general how the landing pattern
is set on this terrain.
There are good aids for this,
namely usually the local pilots,
who know how the landing pattern
is set up in their area.
The standard pattern is a left-hand pattern.
But that can vary depending on the conditions
at the landing site
and may be a right-hand pattern instead,
depending on the wind.
It's usually well marked
at the landing site, visible on a sign.
If not, ask the locals.
Also important
is that we know
where we're actually flying through.
We do a bit of flight planning.
Meaning, when we're at the landing site,
we can already check
where the launch site is.
Usually you can see
where a possible emergency landing site might be.
If a landing site were closed,
which can happen,
say something has occurred,
they have to pick up a hiker
who has broken a leg.
The Rega helicopter lands right on the landing site.
It's important
that we then know
where we'll land instead.
And there are things we have to think about
that we should consider
regarding turbulence.
There are houses,
big trees
that could create turbulence.
A bit of valley wind
that could disturb us during landing.
Making all these considerations in advance
really makes the flight much easier overall,
because you then have a plan B in mind.
And plan B is something very important.
We should never fly somewhere
if we don't know
what we'll do
if it doesn't go
the way we expected.
Always think in advance,
what to do when.
That also includes the consideration
regarding wildlife.
We have wildlife protection as a major topic.
It used to always be a secondary concern.
People used to say
that paragliders
hardly disturb wildlife.
The new study
that just came out
shows rather the opposite,
that the paraglider pilot
does have a bit of responsibility
toward wildlife.
And it's also very important
to keep that in mind.
On the one hand we have
the local wildlife agreements,
which are also on the info board,
usually described near the lift,
where, for instance, there are zones
you should not fly into at all.
But it's also important
to know a bit
about wildlife in general.
And in the theory questions
we know for this topic,
there are also lots of questions
about wildlife protection.
Here, for example, it's about
when our animals in the Alps
have their young,
because that's exactly the time
of spring.
And in spring
we fly beautifully high.
That means
we also reach those places
where, for example, the eagles,
the chamois and the ibex
raise their young.
With eagles, you really have to
expect, from March to May,
that they're sitting on the eyrie
and also defending their territory.
With chamois it's in May,
and with ibex it's in June.
And in this time,
if you see animals,
fly away from them.
It's simply fair to the animal
not to tell yourself something like:
the thermal here
is especially good,
I don't care
if there are chamois below me —
instead, fly away.
The animals already have enough stress
from all kinds of environmental pressures,
so we, as paraglider pilots,
who are so close to nature,
shouldn't cause additional stress.
As I said,
the local conditions
for individual wildlife protection areas
are usually clearly displayed
at the lift stations.
And otherwise, don't be shy here either,
ask the locals.
Everyone is always happy to give information.
When we get to the mountain,
heading toward the launch site,
for many it may be the case
that they already feel a little nervous.
But nervousness is ultimately
a good thing,
because it makes you look at things carefully.
And especially
if you don't know a launch site,
for example doing a hike & fly,
arriving at a terrain
you don't know at all,
it's all the more important
that the guiding principle
written here
is observed.
Namely:
from every launch site
it must
be possible at any time, safely,
to abort the launch.
If we launch from a cliff
where we have only a short run,
and then it drops straight down,
then this condition certainly won't be met
and then it's also not
the right launch site.
Of course, depending on the pilot's skill,
this limit shifts a little.
But this principle applies to everyone
and always.
Then we have, of course,
different criteria
for the launch site.
Meaning, when we arrive,
we first have to know
what kind of wind we have.
If we have a downdraft
i.e. tailwind at the launch site,
then we definitely have to choose a launch site
where we can run for a long way.
Meaning, one that is free of obstacles.
We can't run between stones,
we have to make sure
this section is obstacle-free,
so we can accelerate
and also after lift-off
still need to build speed,
so that it's as obstacle-free and clean as possible.
If we arrive at the launch site
and there's a 20 km/h headwind,
the situation looks of course quite different.
Then we can beautifully
turn around to face the wing
and do a reverse launch.
It can be that
we first have to,
so the wing doesn't overshoot too much,
run toward the wing
up the slope.
That means,
we need to make sure
that we don't have obstacles behind us,
but actually toward the wing,
no obstacles,
so that we don't trip.
The same applies with crosswind.
If we have a bit of crosswind there,
we may need to
pull the wing up against the wind
and then run a small distance
in the fall direction.
Then there must be
as few obstacles as possible.
And that's an important criterion
for the launch site.
That also belongs to
crowd gathering.
Especially at public launch sites
that are reached by lift,
you very quickly get lots of spectators.
These spectators are, on one hand, nice
because they watch our sport,
on the other hand it also poses a danger.
Meaning, they may want to talk to you,
they want their questions answered,
and all of that distracts you.
So it may also make sense
to choose a launch site
where you have a bit of peace.
Especially if you're a bit
uncertain,
if you still need to internalise
the whole launch process.
Take your time,
work calmly,
never hectically,
and then there will also be a clean launch.
When you're ready
to start the launch,
one thing is indispensable,
namely that you do a proper check.
And the check,
you've already,
if you've been to the training slope,
certainly learned it there,
is also a very big topic in theory
and it should always
be done conscientiously.
It actually starts
when the harness is on the ground
and you pick it up and put it on,
because then, and only then,
can you properly check
that your reserve handle is sitting cleanly in the harness.
Are the two pins —
most have two,
there are also harnesses with only one —
is the pin really still in,
as it should be,
is the handle properly attached,
does anything look off,
as if something isn't right —
and that's what you can do
when you pick up the harness,
first you check the reserve parachute
and then you put it on.
And then for the 5-point check
the easiest
is to start with the body.
We go from inside to outside.
Namely,
with the reserve parachute already checked,
we then move on
to all our buckles.
Are they closed and secured?
For me, that includes shoelaces,
for me that also includes
the helmet straps.
It's simply important
that all buckles
are closed and secured.
Point 1.
Point 2.
We then go further
from us outward,
namely to the risers.
Are they not twisted?
And do our lines,
going to the wing,
run as we want them to?
That is,
have we sorted them,
is there no knot in there,
do they lie
the way we want?
And then we come to point 3.
Is the wing lying as desired?
Also,
the way we want?
Is it nicely open
and aligned with the wind?
And point 4.
We then move to wind direction
and, important, wind strength.
It's no use
if we have the right wind direction
but a 50 km/h slope updraft
or a 20 km/h tailwind.
Then the strength is certainly not right.
And then point 5.
Are the launch path and airspace clear?
For that, just look up again quickly.
Yes,
there are no
other pilots flying past.
And the launch path
is really clear.
Are there no children
or animals around
that could suddenly
during the launch procedure
walk into your launch path?
If that's the case,
then better wait,
send the children away,
wait
if the cow wants to graze a bit more,
and only then launch.
I can imagine
if you, with your mass,
let's say,
I'm 80 kilos
with the paraglider and everything,
I'm quickly 100 kilos
and I accelerate to 20 km/h,
then that's a kinetic energy
that, for whoever
I might hit,
can very quickly become really dangerous.
If we're doing a reverse launch,
we have good wind,
we can do a perfect reverse launch,
then we turn around after the 5-point check
toward the wing.
Now from points 1 to 4
not much changes anymore,
but what can change again
is,
namely that the launch path
or for example the airspace
is no longer clear.
So immediately before the reverse launch
repeat point 5 carefully again.
Then we slowly proceed to the launch
and you've probably heard of it,
the so-called 3-phase launch.
Namely, we begin with the inflating phase,
then comes the control
and correction phase,
and then comes the acceleration phase.
And it's very important
that we think of it in these three steps.
Many pilots at the launch site
go too far ahead in their minds,
they're already in the air
or already accelerating.
Instead of simply saying:
first I'll do point 1 and point 2 cleanly,
namely inflating,
control and correction,
and then I decide:
everything is the way I want it,
I feel safe,
it feels good,
then I go into the acceleration phase.
And don't do all 3 at once,
because the control and correction phase
is exactly there
so that we recognise a mistake.
The wing is, say, crooked,
we have a knot in the line,
we have something that doesn't suit us —
we abort.
If we're already in the acceleration phase,
we're already there,
an abort can no longer happen,
because as the word says,
acceleration,
we're moving fast
and we want to leave this zone
as quickly as possible,
namely into the air,
because in the air we're safe again.
There we no longer have obstacles to hit,
we can no longer trip,
in the air everything is fine again.
Important is:
do 1 and 2 cleanly
and then decide,
yes, fits, accelerate,
or no, doesn't fit,
abort.
Incidentally, in a practical exam too,
as long as you abort in point 1 or point 2,
that's a clean abort
and no problem.
If you abort in point 3, the acceleration phase,
then you didn't do point 2 cleanly
and that can mean a negative point in the exam.
Important after that,
when we reach lift-off speed,
is that we also lift off
and very importantly,
that you don't release the brakes after launch.
We see it again and again in practice,
that people fly out
and want to get comfortable in the harness relatively quickly.
That's well and good for comfort,
but it carries a risk,
namely that you release the brakes.
And now you have some disturbance
that you maybe didn't even notice during launch
or a bit too much crosswind
and the wing pulls relatively quickly to one side.
And that's simply connected with dangers,
so only sit into the harness then,
only get comfortable then,
when you're flying far, far straight
in the desired flight direction,
have lots of air below you,
then you can release the brakes briefly
and get comfortable
and then take the brakes again.
Now there's also the situation
where you notice immediately after launch
that you're not flying straight
but to the right or to the left.
That can have various causes.
It can, for example, be
that already during launch
we weren't cleanly into the fall line,
but started a bit at an angle.
It can be that we have a knot
that we didn't see
in the line.
Or it can also be
that we have a strong crosswind
pushing us a bit to one side.
Absolutely most important —
and this should actually be the fourth point
in the 3-phase launch.
And the fourth point is actually
the right stabilisation in the
direction we want.
Namely, straight away from the terrain.
And that must be absolute priority,
no matter what the reason is
that we go to one side.
First cleanly shift weight,
efficiently steer with the opposite brake so firmly
that we fly straight,
far, far out,
build distance between us
and the ground
and then take care of the problem.
If we don't do this,
the dangers involved are, I think,
quite obvious.
Namely that we go uncontrolled
back toward the slope.
And depending on the terrain
it's of course not smart
to land in there.
A landing I wouldn't prefer.
I'd always fly out into open airspace,
because then I buy myself time
to react.
And here it's again good —
the bigger my time window,
the more calmly I can tackle the problem
and react accordingly.
Important is, if we have a problem —
let's now take, say,
still a knot in the line,
even though we did our check cleanly.
And we even did the 3-phase launch,
point 2 cleanly done,
namely control and correction,
and stupidly still have
a knot in the line
that we didn't see
and we're now flying out.
Important is: stabilise,
fly straight,
as already discussed.
And speaking of knots,
in their whole flying career
there's probably no pilot
who says they've never had a knot.
Or rather, ever had one.
It's something
that you simply go through,
because we have loose lines
and usually in rocky places,
where you might have pebbles
or tall grass,
where a knot can form.
It's not tragic,
as long as you know
how to deal with it.
Important is,
when we have it,
fly out,
open airspace,
now I take care of the problem
and now I first look
at what the problem is.
Do I recognise,
aha,
I really do have a knot now.
If I have this knot,
then I can decide,
do I get this knot to open?
There are various tools
for opening the knot.
That can, for example, be
that I give an impulse with the brake
on the knot side.
It can be
that the knot opens again.
that I pull on the stabilo line,
that's the outermost colour,
usually the trim line,
that goes to the stabilo,
that I pull this down.
Or I have a knot, for example,
that's at the front,
with a collapse,
a 50% collapse,
which we'll come back to later,
how that's done,
I can unload the wing in such a way
that there's a good chance
that the knot opens again.
When the knot opens,
great,
then we fly on,
enjoy this flight.
If the knot doesn't open.
And we can hold the state
of flying straight
for the time being,
by shifting weight firmly,
applying a bit of opposite brake,
and flying straight.
Then we have to decide,
can we land like this?
And if we can answer this question
with 100%,
answer it,
then we do it.
Then we land like this.
But if we're uncertain
and say,
flying straight,
fine, that works,
but now for landing
I'd also have to do turns
and also turn into the wind
and I don't even know
where the landing site is,
then we'll quickly
become overloaded.
Then it makes absolute sense,
as long as we can still steer,
over a large field,
preferably not over woods,
to fly over a large meadow
and then deploy the reserve parachute.
Reserve parachute situations
we'll come back to later,
but at least you've heard about it once.
The dog-leg curve.
The dog-leg curve is actually what
we want to avoid,
because it ultimately
costs us flight path
and time,
meaning
we arrive at lower altitude
at the point
where we want to.
If we now aim at a point
and we have no wind,
then we just fly toward it
and arrive as nicely high
as we want.
If we now, however,
have a crosswind component,
in this case from the left,
and we simply
fly toward the point,
then there's a so-called
dog-leg curve
and we make,
exaggerated,
a large detour
and arrive noticeably
lower at the point
than maybe we want.
That's why we have to
choose a wind-correction angle.
The wind-correction angle is nothing other than
the angle between
the longitudinal axis of the wing
and the flight path
we choose.
And if we choose this
a bit into the wind,
then we make a nice,
straight line
toward the point
and arrive optimally
where we want.
to be.